I want to talk a little bit about
infrastructure you know that generally
Republicans are against stimulus type
spending they're against infrastructure
spending they're instead about improving
the economy by cutting spending which
just doesn't really work the idea of
cutting your way to a great economy it
doesn't make any logical sense and
what's fascinating is that Donald Trump
recently unveiled a plan to spend about
a trillion dollars rebuilding America's
infrastructure this is four times the
amount that Hillary Clinton has proposed
spending a trillion dollars that is and
it's fascinating that the Republican
government spending plan is way bigger
than the Democrats but the irony is even
bigger than that because there's
Republicans in Congress who opposed a
plan for infrastructure spending that
was only ten percent the size of Donald
Trump's when it was proposed by
President Obama and the 2009 House
Republican but the group of House
Republicans in oh nine unanimously
opposed President Obama's economic
stimulus now by the way it just so
happens that the way Trump has concocted
the stimulus plan is a huge basically
just windfall for crony capitalism the
way it works is private investors can
buy into a sixth of the project they get
huge tax breaks on the revenue that the
project generates
if it generates revenue so it's a way to
get private industry involved in
government infrastructure spending at
very little risk and to incentivize
short-term success on projects that long
term could be bridges that fall apart
after ten years or whatever so number
one the entire way Trump conceived this
thing is ridiculous but isn't it funny
that normally Republicans Republicans
elected officials Republican voters
they're against the government spending
the government shouldn't spend the
government shouldn't be doing all these
contracts got bad bad bad and we happen
to have a Republican nominee who wants
to spend four times as much as Hillary
Clinton on infrastructure and there are
a few Republicans who are like Ana it's
not really conservative but by and large
if a Republican proposes it all
sudden it seems that government spending
is fine the Republicans are arguing okay
well the projects are actually now going
to be selected with less political
interference and we're going to have
more money for costlier and riskier
projects the big picture even though
Trump wants to spend more money than
than Hillary Clinton on infrastructure
is that trumps economic platform is
still based around privatization of
government functions right a total
private free-market a health insurance
system allow contractors to buy in to
that government infrastructure spending
in a way that is hugely beneficial to
them without guaranteeing the benefits
to the American taxpayer that actually
is in line with what Republicans in the
Republican Party have been pushing for
for a while the difference is the way in
which Trump is saying the infrastructure
is crumbling and the government needs to
spend a ton of money the optics of that
are not exactly what it is that that
Republicans usually do and and you know
this is the direction of this is listen
air air is a very valuable commodity and
it's increasingly scarce so why is it
more and more scarce oh because of the
polluting done by big corporations due
to not enough regulations but forget
about that we're going to actually make
access to clean air a free-market thing
if you want to pay for clean air then
you'll get it and if you don't well if
you're really really poor maybe the
government will help you get some clean
air but otherwise if people really want
clean air they've got to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps and they can buy
the clean air with what money I have no
idea that's more or less what's
happening in China and it's also
happening if you look at a lot of these
plastic factories in Texas poor people
can't afford to live anywhere other than
downwind from the pollution generated by
these plastic factories it causes cancer
and Republicans are basically okay with
that you can buy free air I'm sorry
clean air if you can afford it